okay so i set up last night waiting for
the she-hulk trailer to drop but i fell
asleep at my desk by about 10 o'clock
because then bloody twins they had me up
at 4am yesterday kevin spoilers is late
with his trailer breakdown however i've
had time to sit reflect if you will and
throughout this video we're going to be
going over all the easter eggs hidden
details and new characters in the
she-hulk trailer we even have a brand
new logo and there's some what gets in
there and what i believe is the law firm
glkh which we see pop up behind the
character
being a superhero
is a trial by fire
who's gonna protect the world if not
people like you
i'm jennifer walters i'm a lawyer i have
great friends can we get some shots
please it's an emergency a demanding job
we just started a superhuman law
division and i want you to be the face
of it
now early on we're introduced to
jennifer walters a lawyer who's being
put in charge of the superhuman law
division there are rumors that matt
murdock will also be appearing in the
series and this comes hot off the heels
of his appearance in spiderman no way
home early on in the teaser we also
catch certain shots being awash with
colour filters and this is potentially
hinting at the kinds of hulks we could
be getting blue is for the abomination
which we'll talk about more in just a
bit red is for red hulk or potentially
red she hulk and they are possibly
teasing certain characters showing up i
know william hurt sadly passed away
recently as well so it is unlikely that
we'll be going the red hulk route but
those are the options that we could have
however the red could also belong to
daredevil which would be great to see if
charlie cox is in the series now there's
a swat team with specialized weapons
that open up the new look and this
appears to be at the party that she-hulk
arrives at later on in the trailer this
is likely the superhuman lord division
that she's high to be a part of and
potentially she'll be working alongside
it and it's boss throughout the show now
the superhuman lord division is
something that we see the building of in
the trailer in the comics this is known
as the cube a giant inescapable prison
used to hide the most deadly kinds of
criminals it's basically the land
version of the raft tasked with locking
up supervillains such as the abomination
who appears throughout in the civil war
run jennifer was put in charge of being
a lawyer to several of those that
refused to sign the superhuman
registration act and she dealt with many
of their defense cases they were
transported into another reality in
order to be imprisoned as they wouldn't
have any rights there and it's going to
be interesting to see how this major
structure operates in the comics and
show jennifer walters is actually the
cousin of bruce banner and she was also
the daughter of a los angeles county
sheriff named william morris walters we
get a reference to this in the teaser
when bruce calls her his cous and it'll
likely follow the same lines as that
within the source of material bruce went
to see her to tell her he was the hulk
and she was attacked by some mobsters
that we could potentially see in the
trailer at one point we get a brief
flash of a gang and currently there's a
lot of speculation that this could be
the wrecking crew made up of the bad
guys wrecker obviously thunderball
bulldozer and piledriver these are
villains that are known for using
crowbars much like what we see here
already starting off with the reaches
but this crowbar actually ended up
getting magical powers from carnila the
non-queen i doubt we will go that goofy
but if we are doing a deep dive on this
then it's possibly linked to them beyond
this they've also been attached to gamma
devices in the comics at one point they
were given the job of retrieving a gamma
bomb though the show could adapt this
and change it so that they go after the
secret of how bruce passed his powers
onto jennifer after jennifer was put in
the hospital she was desperate for a
blood transfusion and bruce ended up
having to provide some of his own due to
them being relatives this gang then
arrived at the hospital to finish the
job and kill her before she could
identify them which triggered her
transformation in the comics she hulk is
way smarter than your typical version of
the hulk and she's pretty much retained
every aspect of her personality so i'm
thinking that this transfusion was done
whilst bruce was still smart hulk and
thus this dna meant that she didn't flip
out and turn into a giant green rage
monster i think it's also possible that
the crash we see at the start could be
the accident that she ends up in but let
me know below exactly what you think now
we do see her potentially transforming
in this moment later on in the trailer
so potentially this is her first time
changing this could be roughing on the
70s hulk show as the first
transformation in that also had to do
with a car crash but in order for this
to happen the gang origin would have to
be set up there are further nods to this
in the show as the first teaser even had
moments riffing on the bell bixby era
with even the same clouds being used
there's also an air horn shot at her
face at one point and her eyes should
open similar how bruce banner
transformed in that show now hulk works
on her in a gamma lab and this could
potentially be the one that he brought
up in avengers endgame bruce said that
he spent months inside of one putting
together the best of both worlds and it
seems like we'll be going through the
same processes with jennifer in order
for her to be able to gain full control
of her hulk's side we also have a moment
where the pair both meditate which is
raped right out of the incredible hulk
movie in which bruce try to control his
anger he ends up putting her through her
paces even sending buzzsaws at her at
one point in order to trigger her
transformation shins are blowing the
bloody doors off and this could be
hitting at the more powerful rage
monster hulk that exists inside of her
it also looks like bruce has taken her
to a remote island to train because it's
obviously dangerous letting a hulk off
the leash in a populated area i find it
interesting that bruce's arm is
completely healed and at the end of
avengers end game it was badly damaged
but i hope this wasn't his one righting
hand now at the end of chongqi bruce was
back but his arm was in a sling and it
makes me wonder about the timeline of
the series potentially this show could
happen in the five years between the
snap in the blip and this is why hulk's
arm is healed and he's not back to being
bruce might have been a mistake on the
continuity part of the mcu or perhaps
bruce can now transform between himself
and smart hulk hulk has a healing factor
so it would also explain why his arm is
going back to normal now according to
the leaks this show is set after endgame
so yeah maybe they'll just explain it
away with the healing
your transformations are triggered by
anger and fear
those are like the baseline of any woman
just existing
oh
i feel like if i don't transform i'm
gonna die
yes yes yes no
no
another interesting aspect is that
abomination is in the teaser in both his
human form and transformed state you
might recognize him as being in the cell
that we saw through the portal after the
fighting scene in chongqi wong had
likely been sneaking him in and out in
order to train him so that he can
finally be useful to society like me
when i stopped spoiling movies now he's
looking way more like his comic book
counterpart and i prefer this design to
what we got in the first incredible hulk
movie it seems like this cell stops him
from escaping as he transforms but he
bangs his head on the ceiling which then
stops him escaping other characters that
will be popping up are frogman and
titania frogman is a pretty wacky
character that's basically just a guy in
a frog suit and at one point in the
teaser they talk about superheroes
you could be an avenger oh i'm not a
superhero
that is for billionaires and narcissists
and adult orphans for some reason
could eventually change up his origin as
in the comics his father was an inventor
and i'd love to see this as a batman
spoof with him being a rich adult orphan
or something she's of course at this
point making fun of iron man though and
when you think about it a lot of
superheroes are orphans a lot of
characters disney owns actually a lot of
them are orphans and there's also
titania who attacks she-hulk mid-trial
played by jamila jamil she was a scrawny
kid who grew up jealous that strong
superheroes were admired eventually she
transformed into what we see here and
she ties heavily in with secret wars
which you might be potentially getting
sooner than you think in jennifer's room
we also see a poster for the play
midsummer night's dream and this is
about four boys falling in love with the
same girl after they're put under a
spell by a fairy jennifer jennifer yeah
she ends up dating four men at the end
of the trailer so it could be that hey
i'll tell you what you should have
watched emergency awesome's video if you
wanted actual good easter eggs you chump
see ya chump
also one of these dudes is actually a
wrestler called david otunga who was
actually a liar before the wwe so nice
corporate synergy there now there is
quite a fun vibe to the trailer and
though it's not jam-packed with easter
eggs there's a lot of cool little things
going on in it i know people are having
issues with the cgi and yet i do kind of
agree that at some point it looks quite
bad i think they've probably shown most
of the she-hulk shots in this trailer
and i can imagine that they'll have
jennifer walking around in her normal
state for most of the show however there
are points where she's just chilling in
dresses and having fun which is a big
part of the she-hulk persona the main
thing that differentiates her from her
cousin in the comics is that she can
keep her mental state intact whilst he's
hulking out so i kind of think they
might have this whilst embracing her
powers as the show seems to be dealing
with her not wanting to become a
superhero ah that old trope but as uncle
ben says with great power comes great
dates with hunks that have muscly women
fetishes and it seems like we're gonna
watch as she slowly accepts she has to
become a hero i'm guessing that titania
will probably be the big bad in the show
as it looks like the abomination is
reforming and that jennifer is probably
gonna be acting as his lawyer at some
point as with my thoughts yeah it's a
cool teaser and it's very comic book
accurate i am excited for it and it's
going to be interesting to see how much
they lean into the meta side of it in
the comics she-hulk regularly breaks the
fourth wall so they might end up making
it along the lines of ali mcbeal which
is something that the creative team
brought up when pitching the show the
series is called she-hulk attorney at
lore leaning into the idea it's a
procedural show and it's going to be
interesting to see how it plays out i
just keep getting angry because they
keep pushing this this woke agenda when
when's bloody he hulk coming out when's
when's he hulk coming out when
hype level is probably at a seven right
now and it might be because i'm tired i
just didn't get a sense of an
overwhelming threat of villain which is
normally what gets me excited for these
shows you've just had one of the best
villains in arthur harrow so i'm hoping
this series can deliver both a great
main performance and a villain to match
it anyway that's my thoughts and of
course love to hear yours in the
comments below we are in a competition
right now and giving away three copies
of the batman on the 15th of june and
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the trailer we pick the comments at
random at the end of the month and the
winners are the last one on screen right
now see if that's you then message me on
twitter at heavyspoilers if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our doctor strange
breakdown linked on screen right now
last marvel project we covered was quite
a big one so definitely go head over
there right after this without the way
thanks for sitting through the video
i've been poor let's see in the next one
take care peace